you
game on we have efore let's try let's
try the French why not let's see we have
queenie to know alright
if queenie - I'd play Bishop e7 and then
d5 so I want to be able to recapture
here so let's go with this
the French Widow R and c5 strike at the
base of the center and actually I didn't
want to play this did I well I guess I
have to go down this road
what was I thinking I wanted to play oh
um
something else with like eventually
getting my Bishop out to a6 anyway okay
let's let's run with this here so what's
the idea the idea is some lines to play
Queen here let's first get my knight
here so I could maybe meet Queen g4 with
Knight f5 that's something that I have
in the back of my mind and ideally I'd
like to have the LightSquared Bishop
Soph but I guess he's gonna run away and
along this diagonal but even so I think
my bishop on this diagonal will be good
hmm let's develop let's get my knight on
c6 Queen egg 5 Queen 85 to a4 is an idea
ooh now that's different striking here
huh I haven't seen that before
let's get my Queen now let's see how
white reacts to that I'm threatening to
take on d4 right now with my knight or
pond so in this pawn is unprotected so
the next move has to be Bishop here or
Queen here you have to defend the pawn
and to break the pin to things so I
think I scoot the Queen up just like
that
and this becomes often quite
uncomfortable by keeping a piece on this
square and preventing this pond from
moving
believe it or not that could actually
secure an eventual queenside castle
position also the night might want to
reposition get to see four I could play
night here I think I might want to do
that
it's Queens opposite mine there might be
some tricks with like taking on the e5
square if she's unprotected so I think I
do this first it's a little bit awkward
notice I didn't really want to my first
thought at least maybe maybe it's better
but at least my first thought was not to
play g6 and weaken my dark squares I'm
that's the one piece that I'm lacking
and actually while defending g7 I'm also
attacking d4 yet again and now that the
more I think about it I'm hitting this
pawn as well so I could take here or
here I'm hitting this pawn one two three
four times and it's defended three so I
could take it but I'm wondering if I
should take this pawn or even consider
h5 now I'm fine with where the Queen is
AB if I take here I'm not really in a
position to take again because my queen
is unprotected so let me consider I
wonder if little Queen c4 like to get
the Queen's off what about taking the
pawn playing here after Queen g5 h6 and
then I kind of like that I'm gonna want
to take this pawn take it on c2 okay and
play Queen here
let's give that a shot Queen trade why
not
I'm out material just a little bit I'm
up a pond so that's that's enough for me
to say all right let's let's go I mean
you know what it can't be avoided the
more I look at it because she's putting
pressure on f3 so the one move I thought
could be played Bishop f4 could be met
with h5 and the queen is then kicked
from the defense of the night
so you either take my queen or keep the
tension as is and maybe improve upon one
of your other pieces or do that grab a
pawn all right let's take the let's take
that and now maybe I just run away yeah
I really don't want that capture once
again I'm not doing this move I did
consider it so that if captures I could
take towards the center but I'm very
very hesitant to weaken my dark squares
and I need to need to pick up the pace
let me watch over this square I think I
want to oh boy what do I want to do
finish that thought all right I want to
definitely keep the knight out of this
square because if he gets here he's
getting a d6 this pine wild doubled is
very annoying you know what I don't want
I don't want I don't want to see f5 and
now I'm doing this move you'll notice
only after that I know the bishop can't
make use of this square and get in on
the dark squares I also want to yeah I
wanted to move my bishop and queenside
castle that's gonna be tough to do
though isn't it this is tough not really
liking my position very much I'm down
less than a minute
this looks crazy but I'm gonna go for it
get my king on this square and then move
my Bishop to d7 I have to watch over the
e6 square as well I think I could have
done better I think I go looking back I
think I could have played it in a way
where I'm up material now it's still
balanced these are weak pawns but
they're just still so annoying so let's
get over here I think maybe doubling and
preventing me from playing Bishop here
would have been a an idea so I mean if
if white goes forward with that now I
mean I'm considering Bishop d7 rook H to
b8 yeah look at look at the pressure
there's a lot of pressure here am I
gonna be able to untangle I think so
let's get over here wow he's a brilliant
piece isn't he
it's a brilliant piece on a8 I want to
give this rook a kick get out of my
house maybe not I'll let you stay there
I'm missing anything might be some
accident over here I want to get to c4
don't get my other night here 38
catching up a little bit on time all
right let's trade a little bit take my
night hmm no I might want to give a pawn
just to activate my rooks I'm gonna try
that I'm gonna give up my bishop good
night versus bad bishop and I'm down
upon but I get some good activity Knight
c4 super active and this rook is trapped
how do you like that
Wow
that was a look what I found type of
move
but these prawns could be quite
dangerous you know what that rooks going
no where is he he's still stuck so no
need to take him I'm hitting this bishop
I'm looking to win him for free free of
charge I want that rook heard this
bishop I think I still just done move
fast
bishop here I end up winning the piece
this Knight is very powerful very very
powerful all right now I'll take pawn
takes I scoot over rook takes I just
activate 21 seconds move I should have
given it no not that not to check what
am i doing
just want to trade can we trade here all
right I definitely have to pick up the
pace here I'm gonna move upon just keep
it locked up over there 15 10 second
difference let's trade a little bit I
love a trade we're gonna go back and
forth a little bit throw this check in
all right I'm okay with that
I can function on these light squares
and it's much easier to make pre moves
swing over here there's no tricky stuff
almost there's almost something tricky
right there finally I could track down
this pawn and get this pawn rolling
Oh for a second I thought I was down on
time oh not the case not the case good
game let's go back hmm let me look at it
from your perspective let's go back here
so French win war I felt like I should
have got something better out of the
opening to be really honest here
III was not too common scene Queen G for
Queen G for Knight f3 I've seen h4 I'm
not sure the exact this exact move but
just just throwing some different
possibilities out there queen g4 to put
pressure on g7 h4 h5 trying to make some
weakness and then a rook left is an idea
as well as a4 and Bishop e3 getting the
bishop on this diagonal I haven't really
seen this idea before with the g3 and
the bishop playing to h3 and I wonder if
I could have done I wonder if I could
have done better at this point right
here it seems like there's hmm I'm
hitting this pun three times now I can't
win it just yet and now it's being hit a
lot maybe I should have just taken that
pawn instead of taking on c2 I think
this would have just been better take on
d4 yeah he's more important no I'm not
losing that pawn back either that's the
other that's the other big thing or even
or even now I played Queen e4 maybe but
maybe I was too much in a hurry to play
Queen e4 what about taking now on d4 and
only then playing to Eve
efore with the Queen trade that I'm not
having to battle upon in my territory on
that c5 square
turned it to be very cramping to my
Queen side and it it really restricted
my king and my Queen side development
by having that pawn there I couldn't I
couldn't move my let's say beep on so
easily and activate my light square
Bishop let's say on a six so I think at
this point I could have done better with
capturing here and not giving up that
pawn not giving the pawn back and again
notice the my hesitancy with touching my
GG seven pun my jeep on not wanting to
move it
only until f4 was played and f5 was a
threat and I can be sure that the bishop
can't be wouldn't be able to invade on
those dark squares as easily this
position is tough for me to assess I
don't think that I'm any better
you have the bishops you also have a
space advantage indicated by the pawn on
e5 and the pawn on c5 so you have a
space advantage in the center and on the
Queen side and you put some pressure on
b7 this is I mean if I'm having to make
a move like this I mean it's just
another sign I mean look at the time
development or the the the time factor
the development factor you have a lead
in development as well can you really
put that to use wondering the way to do
that normally would be to create pawn
exchanges so the move that kind of comes
to mind is c4 but something needs to
first be done with the tension between
the Knights I wonder if capturing and
then playing c4 is a way to go I'm not
so sure after Knight takes Knight let's
go back here for a second after I make
this King move after Knight takes Knight
I was going to be playing Knight takes
but then maybe this starts to become
very annoying look at my bishop what a
stupid piece you know I never really
solved well I'm not until very very late
in the game that I solve my problem
Bishop my my bad Bishop he never really
got working until very late in the game
but
I think going back even earlier I'm not
so sure about this bishops deployment
maybe it's maybe it's something that's
been played before it's just it's new to
me
I'm not sure I don't have too much
experience on either side really with
this particular pawn structure out of
the French win wire but hopefully
there's some things still that you can
be taking away from this game so I don't
think to too much more at this point and
you have a lot of pressure on me know
that there was a for a second I was
thinking maybe there's some trick
against e6 maybe this was an opportunity
mm-hmm maybe we could sack your knight
and get a very active rook would have me
sweating that's for sure as soon as I
was able to get my LightSquared Bishop
off like this right here and I still
felt a bit more comfortable and I didn't
know that after Knight c4 I was trapping
the rook but I just wanted to make sure
I got activated along the a file and you
not get this pawn back and now I think
the tables start to turn to towards this
end game good night versus bad bishop
okay
good game
you